weeks after the first cases were
discovered in the U.S the White House is
starting to take action to tackle the
spread of monkey pox this week
announcing that tens of thousands of
vaccine doses will be made available but
for some it's too late Gerald feeblis
started seeing The Tell-Tale symptoms of
monkey pox earlier this week
I then found one on my foot and then a
few hours later then I found one on my
on my arm and then the next day I woke
up and they were kind of all over my
body he was one of hundreds of men who
missed out on the vaccine this New York
City Clinic in the Chelsea neighborhood
had just a thousand doses but ran out in
one day because of overwhelming demand
globally there have been nearly 5 000
confirmed monkey pox cases in 49
countries and one death the World Health
Organization emphasized that anyone
could catch the virus although it is
primarily affecting gay men however the
who says it's not yet an international
public health emergency but it could be
soon in the U.S case numbers have
doubled in a week now more than 300 many
experts believe the number is actually
much higher
epidemiologist colesto Macho funny has a
friend who had monkey pox symptoms but
had to wait seven days before he could
finally get a test that came back
positive
for me that's an indication that testing
is not accessible
and
um and so we don't really know what the
numbers are the U.S federal government
said they would release a little more
than 50 000 doses of monkeypox vaccine
immediately to various cities throughout
the United States and about 750
000 doses are expected to be made
available by the end of this summer but
many Health officials worry it could be
too little too late we would need to be
vaccinating widely and we would need to
be doing that
several weeks back I mean it's reported
in multiple States throughout the U.S
and if you did not have 50 000 doses
right now it's not it's not very much
there is only a short window to stamp it
out before it spreads even further My
worry is if we don't deal with this
outbreak here and now especially in a
city like New York then we might be
seeding a pandemic
which is then endemic and that is the
worst case scenario everyone wants to
avoid Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York